[موسيقى]
السودان يغلي والعنف يسيطر
والاشتباكات الداميه مستمره فريقان
متقاتلان كل منهما يتهم الاخر بتدبير
انقلاب تحالف قديم تحول الى عنف
في عصر سوداني جديد لم تقرا معالمه حتى له
فتوتر السياسي والاتهامات المتبادله بين
طرفي المكون العسكري في السودان تمت
ترجمتها على الاقل
قوه الدعم السريع امام الجيش وحميت امام
البرهان
الصوت يعلو سوى صوت القتال والعنف وسيطره
مفقوده وتائهه بين طرفين
الجيش السوداني اعلن اسقاطه وسيطرته على
اكبر قاعده لقوات الدعم السريع في كلاري
والاستيلاء على كل اليات واسلحه واعتاد
الدعم السريع اما الاخر فتقول انها تسيطر
على معظم المنشاه العسكريه في البلاد
الصراع مستمر بين الجانبين ويبدو ان
المعركه لم تبح بعد بكل اسرارها الا ان
هناك بعض الارقام التي تبين الفرق بين قوه
الفريقين واعتادهم العسكري
فالجيش السوداني الذي تاسس عام
1956 يمتلك من ناحيه الطرسانه العسكريه
الجويه نحو 191 طائره حربيه وعلى الارض
لديهم 170 دبابه وتسعه الاف مركبه عسكريه
وعشرون مدفعا ذاتيه الحركه
و389 مدفعا واربعون راجمه
ويحتل الجيش السوداني المرتبه الخامسه
والسبعين عالميا في قائمه اقوى جيوش
العالم بنحو ربع مليون جندي
اما قوات الدعم السريع التي تاسست عام
2013 فيبلغ تعدادها العسكري نحو 100 الف
جندي ولا تمتلك اي طائره ولا يوجد لديها
سلاح جوي لكن لديها مدرعات خفيفه وسيارات
دفع رباعي مسلحه وانواعا مختلفه من
الاسلحه الثقيله والخفيفه وهناك بعض
التقارير تشير الى امتلاكها انظمه تجسس
دقيقه ومسيرات متطوره
ومن حيث الانتشار على الارض تمتلك قوات
الدعم السريع مراكز في ولايه السودان
معظمها في دارفور وشمال كردفان وغربها
ولديها تواجد كبير بولايه البحر الاحمر
ومواقع قرب حلين كما اسست مقر عديده في
الخرطوم استولت سابقا على مقرات
استراتيجيه مثل جهاز الامن الوطني ومقر
جهاز المخابرات السابق ومقر هيئه العمليات
القريب من مطار الخرطوم الدولي ومبنى لحزب
المؤتمر الوطني المنحرف
[موسيقى]
المعادله السودانيه الصعبه ليست وليده
اليوم والحرب الاهليه باتت تلوح في الافق
بحسب مراقبين وبهذا الصراع اصبح انتقال
السلطه الى المدنيين امرا بعيدا على الاقل
خلال المرحله الروحينه